rachel's with us in miami florida hi
rachel how are you
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um i'm so happy to be on here i've been
listening to you guys for a while
so i have a car that's
worth about two thousand dollars but i
owe 2900 on it
and i'm not sure whether to repair it or
sell it
and then get a new one um caveats it is
under
my mom's name and um
other than that the car is running but
there's no ac
and i'm in miami it's pretty hot and all
the colts to 60 ac
et cetera are running about to a
thousand dollars
what what kind of car is it it's a mazda
cx7
like a mini suv what's your income
so right now my income is about 2 000 a
month
but i have about
12 000 in savings um
but i am interviewing at a for a
management consulting company so i'm
interested
right now for a job that will give me
about 160 000 but again
i'm interviewing it's a big jump
that's a little change well yeah
i'm normally a freelancer so i decided
i'm a freelance consultant so i was like
you know what let me just go for
actually working for a consulting
company like mckenzie or boston
consulting group
okay wow all right i sure hope you pull
that off that'll be amazing
how old are you i'm 33.
excellent okay um
well go back to your original question
on the car itself the formula on a car
regardless of what's owed on it
if do i fix the car you ask yourself
what can i sell the car
for today and what could i sell it for
if i fixed it
if the difference is not equal to the
repair
you sell it now without fixing it so let
me give you an example
okay you said the car is worth two
thousand dollars if you spend a thousand
dollars on it does it make it worth
three
no it probably doesn't no not according
to carmax which i talked to them and
they were like
carmax is not selling carmax is buying
the car from you at wholesale
yeah they're buying it from you where
they can resell it and make a profit a
car like you've got should be sold to an
individual and you can make more on
it so you need to go to
kellybluebook.comkbb.com and look and
see what this car is worth on a private
sale so you put on craigslist and you
sell it to somebody
okay and let's use those numbers now you
do have a thousand dollars worth of
repairs to do to it i
do not think that the thousand dollars
worth of repairs is going to make the
car worth one thousand dollars more
on a two or three thousand dollar car i
don't think that's going to happen so
you're probably going to sell it as
is and you're going to have to write a
check in order to do that
if you sold it for 2 and you owe 2 900
you have to write a check for the 900
difference right
yes and then you got to write a check
and buy a car
yes which i'm definitely afraid of
because i
do only have 12 000 and i haven't landed
the new job and i just want to make sure
that
i don't put myself in a weird situation
yeah well i wouldn't
i i would spend uh no more than four or
five thousand dollars on a car in this
situation
and then if you start making 160 in a
year take that five thousand dollar car
and buy you a fifteen thousand dollar
car
but you save up and pay cash for it
either way
okay so if you sell this car and you
write five thousand dollars out and you
go buy another little used car of some
kind
um so you should probably uh if you're
going to do that
uh two things i think of is one
find a good local independent mechanic
that will pay charge you a
small fee for inspecting the car and
looking it over for you
okay and number two
um do you have um
uh if you're in a church do you have
some older guys in the church that might
help you
in this purchase or do you have an uncle
or a dad or something that might help
you in the purchase it is not that
you're not capable
but sometimes uh people around the car
business
might treat a 33 year old lady
differently than they would a crusty old
dude
well if it's your first time doing it it
is because this
would be the first car under my name
it's either been a company or my parents
yeah yeah would your dad go with you and
look at it with you and give you advice
and also kind of
uh back the boo dubs off on the car lot
to where you get
actually get a good deal
yeah i could go with my dad or my
boyfriend yeah either one
either one's fine and i'm not being
sexist but i'm telling you that people
in that business might be
i think you're perfectly capable of
doing it i just don't want you to get
mistreated
and i want you to get the best possible
deal and so i'm going to use every
technique
in the book well if you've never done it
before rachel like you're saying
then you wouldn't even know if you were
being taken advantage of bernard or not
if i
you know bought a car when i was 22 or
23 or something when it was my first
time
i didn't know the first time i had to
ask everybody to research bring people
with me
by this point i've bought and sold
several cars so i'm confident going into
that in type of environment and i know
what to ask and i know when someone's
trying to
you know be shady but if it's your first
time you wouldn't know how to do that
and so yeah just having all the help in
your corners a great idea